gerson gasparín es un abogado de 29 años
que se inscribió como aspirante para
derrotar a daniel ortega en las
elecciones de noviembre
afirma ser el más fuerte en la contienda
política pero para los nicaragüenses es
un desconocido la competencia va entre
gerson gutiérrez gasparín y alianza por
la república y el candidato del
oficialismo
gasparini afirma que nunca antes
participó en política y ahora debuta en
el apre un partido tildado por la
oposición de colaborar con el
oficialismo y los jóvenes ya se están
enterando quienes gasparín y en ese
candidato que por fin lo tuvo única lo
tiene nicaragua que por décadas nunca lo
ha tenido
pero en las calles nadie conoce a los
candidatos que competirán contra el
sandinismo ninguno ninguno cuando yo
pues porque como los que estaban ya los
que lo cambiaron está preso pues lo
nuevo no se sabe quiénes son casi nadie
sabe eso
solamente daniel no conozco ninguno de
los candidatos que van ahorita
actualmente solamente se puede llegamos
que nuestro candidato es daniel ortega
saavedra verdad porque él es el que ha
hecho obras bastante en nicaragua tras
el arresto de siete aspirantes
presidenciales que contaban con respaldo
popular los comicios en nicaragua
perdieron credibilidad según eeuu y
activistas locales
actualmente los que hay como como se
dice popularmente en estar a dos
partidos
colaboracionistas con el frente
sandinista y se les hace amar pan
partido shampoo que por cierto donde
poder este caso algunas diputaciones
nacional ello comparte d
es decir té de noviembre desde la de las
elecciones
la carrera electoral de nicaragua ha
sido marcada por sanciones
internacionales hacia el gobierno que
lidera daniela ortega y su esposa
rosario murillo acusados de emprender
una cacería contra opositores defensores
de derechos humanos y la prensa
independiente